president Trump's threat to put tariffs
on all goods from Mexico could push up
prices for US consumers the surprise
announcement last night is meant to
pressure Mexico to stop the surge of
undocumented immigrants into the u.s.
the Border Patrol confirmed yesterday it
detained the largest ever group of
migrants near the southern border more
than 1,000 people we Shang is at the
white house we showed the president
calls this a big league statement good
morning Anthony he sure does president
Trump says Mexico could easily and
quickly stop illegal immigrants from
crossing its border but it does not so
to penalize Mexico for the surge of
migrants 5% tariffs would kick in on
June 10th they will be removed if the
illegal migration crisis is alleviated
but if not the tariffs will increase by
5% every month until October then remain
at 25% acting White House chief of staff
Mick Mulvaney said the White House will
judge Mexico success by whether illegal
border crossings decrease but he did not
provide specific targets Mexican
President Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador is
sending a delegation here to the White
House today he says to come to a
peaceful conclusion but in a statement
late last night he also urged mr. Trump
to remember he is quote not a coward
retaliatory Mexican tariffs could mean
that US consumers pay more for limes
avocado tequila among other goods
Anthony we sure how are lawmakers
responding to this tariff announcement
you know even Republicans are condemning
this move yesterday Senator Chuck
Grassley said it is a misuse of
presidential tariff Authority and
Republicans are also worried this will
be a new roadblock for the president's
new trade deal with Canada and Mexico
which is just now starting to make its
way through Congress for approval towing
all right we just thank you very much